we're just counting down the days until
breath of the wild too but until then
we're still finding new things in the
first game to this day so if you enjoyed
this series give this video a like
there's at least one thing you'll learn
with each video alright let's go
ever seen a dragon with the case of the
zoomies
strike it with an arrow right as you go
into bullet time to see it blast off
into the sunset
sand seals are a common sight in the
gerudo desert but have you ever seen one
outside of the desert they will normally
seek out sandy terrain if they are stuck
on something rough but this does mean
any sandy area including beaches by
pushing the sand seal rental lady out of
the desert then freezing yourself as you
talk to her you could smuggle the seal
out of bounds it won't make it too far
on its own on regular old dirt but if
you're dedicated enough for a long trek
you can carry it to another beach and go
for a nice coastal ride
and you can ride seals through shallow
water make sense
these types of wooden platforms aren't
just simple traps that fall down they
hinge both ways like a door going in
both directions
you can even make a maublin drown in a
waterfall this way
i'm sure at some point you may have made
the fatal mistake of having your horse
take a nosedive straight off a cliff
edge and fall to its doom
it was bound to happen but there's still
hope just freeze it with an ice arrow
and it'll be fine when it lands
did you know that the original damaged
master sword actually exists in the game
only available through mods
unfortunately though this actually holds
several interesting tidbits on its own
most players think it's covered in rust
but it's actually malice that's covered
the blade from link's past battles since
this was designed for cut scenes only
and never made it into the final game
development for it was minimal with no
description and only an attack power of
1. but if you listen closely the
sheathing noise is slightly different
that's because it still uses the same
original sound effects from the early
development before they changed it which
could be heard during the e3 2016 build
[Music]
uh that rolling issue we were having
over that crest there
i
did you know that you can crouch through
these doors when they're sideways in
bahrudania
here's a funny fact about the hinox
during the initial development of breath
of the wild they sketched some ideas
about the high knox's habits and quirks
which is pretty cute one of them was the
ability to somersault while that never
made it into this game this attack did
make it into another game age of
calamity
it's fairly hard to notice because most
enemies drop their weapons in a messy
pile when they die but when lionels are
defeated their weapon drops in relation
to where they're located on their body
you can see the sword and shield along
the ground where its arms are and the
bow on the lionel's back in the same
places
these stone slabs are usually a hint for
you to stasis them and launch them away
for goodies underneath but it's much
easier and much more efficient
durability wise if you use a metal bow
or specific weapons to lift up the cover
instead
guardians have recoil when they fire
their laser but their legs help keep
them grounded if you cut off a
guardian's legs altogether you can see
this in action and you can take
advantage of it by firing at their lower
weak spot when it's exposed
robbie's favorite place to relax is in
his lawn chair up on top of the akala
ancient tech lab you can even see an
extra pair of his glasses up here but
did you know he's not looking at the sky
or even death mountain according to
creating a champion he enjoys zoning out
and staring at the ancient furnace which
you have a clear line of sight of from
here he really loves his ancient tech
lozalfo's water shots can be parried or
blocked obviously but there's another
weird way to deflect it by pulling out a
bomb at just the right time it'll knock
away the shot with no problem
[Music]
[Applause]
guardians are pretty terrifying once
they lock their aim onto you they're
guaranteed to fire unless you break line
of sight but there's a really easy trick
that you can use to camouflage yourself
simply magnesis the air then drop any
item yep that's it
then they're unable to lock onto you as
long as you don't move when you mag drop
items it creates what's called a null
item an invisible hitbox that can be
picked up and physically blocks some
things such as launched metal boxes and
guardian's line of sight
this tech is pretty useful in a pinch to
defend yourself against these hulky
machines
the explosive cannonball is actually
kind of weird on closer inspection you
can clearly see what's loaded is a
natural looking boulder inside but when
it's launched it seems to turn into a
perfectly smooth solid manufactured ball
of iron with straight lines wrapping
around the sides of the ball just an
interesting oversight by the developers
or some magical cannon i guess
barrels won't protect you from elemental
damage but do block arrows and dan's
helmet or the thunder helm won't protect
you from the arrow damage itself only
the elemental damage but combine the two
together to defend yourself against a
lionel's dangerous elemental shots
ever wanted to clean up link's look but
still use the shika slate abilities if
you want to walk around slate lists use
the old apparatus storage glitch then
load a file quickly after entering
bullet time the slate will be gone but
you can still use rune abilities and
some cutscenes will be more awkward
[Music]
most people haven't taken a close look
around the final room in the trial of
the sword along the walls you can see
many notable locations of hyrule each in
mostly the right directions according to
the compass such as death mountain the
great deku tree in the great hyrule
forest hebrew mountains divine beast ba
meadow
the thundra plateau
satori mountain with the gerudo
highlands in the background divine beast
bon aboris
the great plateau
dueling peaks
pillars of levia
mount la neru
divine beast varuta
the zora domains giant fish and
shatterback point
there are many divine beast designs that
were sketched out for development four
which made it in and others scrapped but
one of these scrapped beasts actually
sort of still made it in this stingray
beast which is hanging up in the hutano
tech lab
the mystery surrounding link's family
has never really been addressed as
pretty much the only time his father was
mentioned was in this one cut scene your
path seems to mirror your father's
you've dedicated yourself to becoming a
knight as well but there's a secret
photograph that's rarely seen in the
breath of the wild masterworks book
showing link in his champion's tunic
with his father and his sister strange
thing is there's another book called
creating a champion which is the english
translation of the before mentioned
master works and in the english version
specifically this page was replaced
hiding the photograph while it may be
for retcon reasons we will never know if
this photograph is something nintendo
ever wanted us to see
and there you go what was your favorite
thing you learned this time let us know
in the comments below and if you
continue to enjoy new breath of the wild
videos we have a playlist with tons of
stuff we still make to this day for
everything else gaming keep it here on
gamespot
[Music]
[Music]
you